all right time to check in with ted
who's got your most accurate forecast
and ted
this morning it was sunny and hot and
now i see some of the clouds that are
rolling in behind you yeah of course we
had started off with sunshine and the
clouds came in because of the storms
that we had off towards the sorry we're
just we're thinking about the financial
date tonight
hey let's get together for a financial
date night honey
do finances yes all right over some rose
okay uh live look outside to show those
clouds overhead yeah sunshine like
christian hits said but since the
monsoon is out there and these storms
are really popping up i put this out on
social media earlier you saw those
clouds to the south that was a
thunderstorm that was building up south
of mccullar range and it just died out
104 outside right now humidity at 18
52 degrees dew point the reason i'm
showing you those is because those are
on the rise yesterday we were at seven
percent humidity that's going up now
because we are seeing some monsoon
moisture make its way back into the
region some numbers to show you 106 in
sky canyon right now currently 106 also
for centennial hills 106 for north las
vegas 107 sunrise mountain 103 for
whitney ranch 101 for henderson and
mountains edge you're coming 102 along
with rhodes ranch and we'll always
switch up those neighborhoods for you so
nobody's left out 101 for indian springs
trump 103 106 for lafayette let's get to
the radar now okay dry conditions here
yes we're seeing some echoes here on
mount charleston but i'm really thinking
that's just sprinkles a lot of it's not
touching the ground because it is still
so dry up there as well now as we zoom
out plenty of activity in action again i
alerted you on social media earlier
going off here in mohave county in
arizona but notice the direction going
southward so these ones here near
kingman that we did see a dust storm
warning for you this could be headed
towards
havasu lake havasu and also
laughlin and bullhead city so heads up
for you as those storms are heading down
south we're dry here futurecast does
show maybe some activity down in south
county later on tonight but after that
it starts to clear out and then tomorrow
we have chances returning again but
focusing their attention again on mohave
county with only slight chances here so
we'll just keep it in the slight
category for thunderstorms for tomorrow
and then by thursday the monsoon starts
to look at this starts to retreat a
little bit so we'll see a break from
those storms thursday through saturday
with better chances in the mountains
in those days 82 degrees overnight
partly cloudy skies storms will be
mainly south for this evening tomorrow
your high 103 degrees a mix of sun and
clouds with a very slight chance for
thunderstorms tomorrow and anything will
be isolated it will be gusty near those
storms hear your highs neighborhood by
neighborhood 101 centennial hills along
with mountains edge 102 north las vegas
105 green valley 104 for nellis outside
of town we got you covered 99 indian
springs 100 for boulder city and 107 for
loffler here's your 8 day forecast now
slight chances for tomorrow then there's
that lull mainly mountain storms all the
way through saturday those storm chances
increase again on sunday
to tuesday for next week but notice the
temperatures we don't have any extreme
heat so we're not expecting any
excessive heat in this eight day
forecast even some 90s by the time we
get to next week that's your most
accurate forecast brian benjamin loftis
is standing by
in the eight news now i don't know if
your middle name i've known you a long
time i just don't know your middle name
so i threw that in there it is gerald
ted gerald it is
that was my second choice